okay let's talk a little bit about the
drug test thing because i think that
there is actually a story here
donald trump continues to request that
he and joe biden be drug tested either
before or after the upcoming
presidential debate the debate is
tomorrow i hope you'll watch it with me
live on youtube twitch or facebook
and there's a piece of this story that
is distraction
and there's a piece of the story that is
projection so let's talk about each
donald trump for a while has been saying
joe biden's performance against bernie
sanders during that debate
it was too good biden must have been on
something recently saying that joe biden
got a shot of something remember this
clip from last week
the glove's off this guy doesn't have a
clue he doesn't know where the hell he
is and they'll give him a shot at
something i don't know he's going to get
something he'll be
you know because i watched him so badly
he performed so badly in the debates and
then
with bernie he was average not great but
he got through
and i said what the hell is he taking
and we'd like to ask him and i said that
we want a drug test we want a job test
we'll both take it
we're both right there's the the idea
again
and yesterday donald trump again brings
this up by tweeting quote
i will be strongly demanding a drug test
of sleepy joe biden
prior to or after the debate on tuesday
night
naturally i will agree to take one also
his debate performances have been
setting uneven to put it mildly only
drugs could have caused this discrepancy
i continue to get the sense that there
is projection here
trump talking so much about performing
better in public speaking events
because of drugs because of being on
something and meanwhile the speculation
has been raging for years that it's
trump who is on something and in reality
it is as specific as trump says in the
tweets
but about himself it's trump's public
speaking performances
that are so uneven that it raises
questions we've casually called it
upper trump versus downer trump or
adderall trump versus benzo trump but
the point is what trump
points out in biden these uneven
performances
that's exactly what has raised the alarm
about donald trump trump sometimes very
sweaty with dilated pupils even in front
of bright lights
talking quickly verbal glitches the
shoulder and the the elbow spasms that
we've noticed
other times it's a different person it's
a different guy it's a slowed down trump
seems sad and low energy almost an
ambulant like he's sleep talking
sleepwalking
so that's the projection piece that
trump seems to be pointing out in biden
what we observe in trump
the distraction piece is that even if
trump is on drugs
trump must know that there is not going
to be an actual drug test
before the debate or after the debate so
he can tweet about it and talk about it
with no actual risk
that he will be drug tested and that is
what is meant as distraction it's a
distraction from you know pick your
poison coronavirus
the tax story his attempt to rig the
election in his favor
whatever and by the way in the meantime
we are about 24 hours 30 hours as of
right now from the first debate
does anybody in my audience think either
candidate will back out
because from day one you've had trump
and friends saying
joe biden's going to find a way out so
that he doesn't have to do it
and in the meantime you've had some on
the left saying trump's going to be the
one who finds a way out maybe it'll be
bone spurs or you know whatever
at this late stage just a day before the
first debate
if you think either candidate will back
out for this reason or that reason or
for whatever reason that the debate
isn't going to happen i would love to
hear from you now just one last thought
on this
is it possible that donald trump is
raising the drug test issue
so that when the commission on
presidential debates
doesn't require drug tests which they
obviously will not
trump can say i'm not doing it if we're
not
drug testing i'm not doing it because i
think joe biden is on something a few
people emailed me that idea over the
weekend
i'm running it by you to see what you
think right now
i believe the debate happens but what on
earth do i know but i do think at least
the first debate happens maybe if it
goes horribly wrong
for one or the other candidate maybe
they'll try to figure out a way
not to have the second and third debates
but i believe tomorrow's debate happens
if you disagree with me let me know
real quick i want to tell you about our
sponsor magic spoon
who have done something awesome they've
taken all of our favorite
sugary childhood cereals that we know we
shouldn't eat anymore
and turn them into something you can
actually feel good about eating as an
adult
there's four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry
they taste great they're crunchy they're
sweet like you would expect this type of
cereal to be
but it's perfect for a ketogenic diet
because one bowl has only
three net carbs 12 grams of protein it's
sugar-free
gluten-free grain-free soy free
once our team tried magic spoon for the
first time we actually ended up emailing
magic spoon back and saying can you send
us
more boxes send more samples they've
been a big hit
with david pakman show staffers and
magic spoon
knows how delicious their cereal is
because if you don't like it they'll
refund all of your money no questions
asked
and you'll get free shipping when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n